squad rep bowman predicts civil war if
gop takes control in midterms i do think
that headline is a little strong yeah
what he actually said was
he went on to warn that republicans
gaining control of the house and or
senate would embolden dangerous and
violent extremists to take further
control quote it would also embolden
republicans and the far-right and white
nationalists across the country to begin
to believe that it is their time to not
just take power in the house but the
senate the white house and the state
houses across the country we've got to
understand that this is a group that has
been radicalized by the great
replacement myth and many other things
and have been pushing for violence and
pushing for even civil war so that is
what's at stake right now in terms of
this election he warned i just like to
point out
that it's a ridiculous statement yeah
your republicans just did a deal on gun
control you you don't you don't see
republicans coming out and being like
they're all could you imagine mitch
mcconnell being like i want a machine
gun in the hand of every child like
just there's nowhere nowhere close to
anything like that so to come out and
say they're radicalized but the funny
thing is
what about winning an election makes him
think they will then move for civil war
like exactly people revolt when they're
losing right political system winning in
the political system emboldens a person
to keep trying to pursue more victories
within the political system you know i
don't know about you guys but i'm really
excited about the republicans getting
into power and then sitting on their
hands and doing absolutely nothing
that's wrong you are wrong luke they're
not going to do nothing they're going to
pitch you late to the democrats take
away our rights
no but you are right
they're trying everything they're
throwing everything at the wall and
hoping that it sticks from the roe v
wade uh to obviously this j6 they're
trying everything they can to just throw
it out there to radicalize their base
and uh i don't know i feel like the j6
stuff is not gonna stick with them
because i think a lot of people are
watching this stuff and it doesn't add
up i mean they they have this show trial
don't they have like an an abc uh
producer putting the trial together it's
impossible to watch it it's ridiculous
and people are watching this like is
this really a threat like is this really
the threat is this really is it going to
be climate change is it going to be roe
v wade what is it going to be a police
killing a bunch of black people like
they try everything and i just hope a
lot of people are waking up to like they
just want to manipulate you in radicals
you see jake paul
jake paul came out and was like if you
don't see why voting for biden was the
problem you're the american problem and
he's not like a right winger and you
know uh you know bowman's actually you
know whatever whatever you think of him
he's actually he's he's a lot smarter
than this and he knows that he's
actually stoking division when he goes
this lane he calls himself a progressive
so he understands the struggles of the
working class he should just be honest
and say hey if the establishment
democrats could you know continue on the
way they are we're losing the
working-class vote people can't have you
know even afford gas groceries and
bowman knows that he's a progressive but
he's he's kind of aligned himself with
the establishment ever since he got into
office like the rest of the the squad
who voted for the 40 billion for ukraine
yeah so i want to make a point bouncing
off that i think you're you're
absolutely correct there and one thing i
would add is it's interesting that
someone who's part of the squad which
has very strong leanings if not overt
support for marxist theory would say
that there's going to be a revolt in
this country because the wrong political
faction is winning and not because i
don't know gas is going to reach 8 a
gallon because your average person is
struggling to buy food because people
are incapable of caring for their own
family with a single wage that's the
funny thing but he knows that the thing
is he's smart enough to aoc she knows
that but they decide not to talk about
those issues they have now aligned
themselves with the establishment and i
mean i think the funniest thing about
the uh the squad is they champion
themselves like oh we're the outsider
we're gonna go in and we're gonna fight
pelosi and the establishment they've
just literally aligned with them every
single way yep i think they might start
leaning into the civil war narrative
because the real issue is when people
can't eat when they can't drive when
they can't work
that's when you start seeing the
breakdown i forgot what it's called but
there's like an equation or whatever
that when the cost of uh i think we
talked about it before yeah we did when
the cost of goods reaches a certain
point to the cost to the value of labor
then it just the system breaks what's
the what's the quote we're only three
meals away from a revolution yeah i
forgot who said that uh but someone will
correct me in the comments that was uh
that was just we that was uh it was um
the jurassic drastic world dominion
that's who said it yes exactly yes
that's when we saw the movie together
and that's why it just came to my mind
right now didn't invite me but we didn't
no three meals away from a revolution
exactly and historically we have to we
have to understand whenever there's
civil unrest whenever there's a larger
conflict whether internal or external it
usually is fostered because of economic
instability and chaos this economic
instability is being spurred on by
deliberate decisions by the biden
administration that is literally
shooting this economy in the foot and
this is going to prelude a larger
conflict that's going to unfold in some
kind of way because history dictates
that this is going to happen because it
always happens this way come on man come
on man i totally agree well you agree
with me yeah i know
every now and
then you're completely correct i would
go a little bit further too i think
there's something very unique about the
present economic crisis we're facing
which is that people don't really have
any ability to gauge what normal prices
are because during the pandemic we
actually saw a bit of deflation within
key industries so for example the cost
of a gallon of gasoline where i was
living was like a dollar 45 cents so if
we had a relatively normal cost of
gasoline back in 2020 and it was
something around like 253
and now it was up to five dollars that
would certainly be a problem but when
people are used to gas being
significantly less expensive than the
average and then it shoots up over five
dollars you're going to see massive
economic consequences that which you
wouldn't otherwise see well it's like
it's it's like an inverse big ask right
so here's here this is the trump method
right i think he writes about this in
the art of the deal i haven't read it
but the idea is ask for like twice of
what you want so i'd be like drew give
me a hundred dollars for this you know
drink and then when you're like 100
bucks that's crazy i'll say okay 50 and
you're like ah 50 that's half even
though 50s that you know you ask for way
more than you want this is an inversion
of that where people get used to a real
i'll put it this way
if you were if you were in a place at a
dollar fifty for gas
and it jumps to five bucks you're
looking at a massive increase
if it was already four bucks for like a
year you'd be angry and used to it you'd
be desensitized so this is a much much
bigger shock to people and you'd be
upset by it anyone's going to be upset
by price increases especially if their
wages are not
rising at an equivalent rate but
it's also the fact that people have sort
of lost the ability
to make calculations about what things
should ordinarily cost because nothing's
really been at a normal price for about
two years or so we got a lot of news in
the economy but let's stick to the civil
war topic because even yahoo news
released an article um just moments ago
and it's titled the supreme court could
foster a new kind of civil war so this
is conversation that's being normalized
i was warning about this for you know a
couple years now it's called the divide
and conquer agenda and i think it's
important to understand right now
because from my perspective there's a
bunch of ruling elites manipulating the
left and the right to fight each other
on cultural issues on issues that i
would even regard as petty in some
instances while we are getting screwed
and literally robbed of our wealth and
money and potential to have any kind of
legitimate future for our children so so
i i think you know this term civil war
you've been talking about it forever tim
i i i think is is something that we
should discuss further because
i think there's a big potential for this
well i think
we're in a new kind of civil war already
i've certainly talked about it when you
when you see the left go around
destroying buildings in 2020
529 never forget the leftist
insurrection at the white house where
they tried tearing down the fences they
tore down the barricade set fire to a
guard post and they tried to raise saint
john's church the famous president's
church and 150 officers get injured in
these protests that was an insurrection
the president was forced into a bunker
and they laughed at him for it how many
federal agents and officers of the law
were injured there 150 and tim
here's my point real quick sorry it's
just that where's the where's the the
hearings where are the arrests where's
the uh
where's any republican to come out and
be like look what happened here yeah so
when the federal government and law
enforcement is only going after one
group of people
and the other faction is doing
substantial more substantially more
damage
yeah okay look the gov it's some people
say anarcho-tyranny and i'm like
anarcho-tyranny is like criminals get
away with it but law-abiding citizens
get arrested this is something different
this is antifa and far leftists go
around smashing and destroying and then
the media and the government look away
mm-hmm and then you get a handful of
like
where this patriot front group that no
one believes is real anyway and no one
cares about gets arrested for simply
going into a city they get surrounded
they get a conspiracy charge i mean look
everybody thinks they're feds anyway so
i kind of thought it was funny but if
you're people in a truck and they
surround you and arrest you just for
that i mean you didn't do anything we're
already at a point where two billion
dollars in insurance damage and it was
probably more than that buildings
destroyed burned down all across this
country and nothing 30 30 or so deaths
related to this writing and nothing i
don't care look arrest patriot friend if
they're doing something wrong right but
what about literally the other factions
that are doing substantially worse
nothing is getting done well we
definitely are
uh are in a political psychological
information war that you're seeing
unfold through education through the
mainstream media through movies through
hollywood through music through crt
through all of these agendas and
teachings that come through all these
channels and i think i think the bigger
picture here is it's not necessarily
left versus right it's this global
agenda from the top down and i think the
uniparty is nothing new but i think a
lot of people view it this way where
it's like it's left versus right in the
united states i think that's the way
they want us to view it they want us
into a civil war they want us attacking
each other so it gives this global elite
an excuse for full government overreach
and the the the craziest part about this
entire thing is
people that believe they're on the right
side right which we would say like
people on the left or whatever right
people that think the useful idiots that
are on the ground like tim is talking
about the antifa people the blm people
these far leftists these marxist
professors and universities and you name
it right these people think they're on
the right side because they have the
power in all these institutions
especially big tech that's another one
to name they think they're on the right
side but you're literally being used
just to push an agenda forward so that
the bigger powers at b can come in and
just have an excuse to take over
everything and anyone that's not in line
at that point doesn't matter whether
you're on the left or the right if
you're not in line with the power
structure or the agenda you're gone
absolutely one of the biggest hurdles to
the expansion of authoritarianism in
this country is the constitution what's
the easiest and fastest way to get rid
of a constitution emergencies civil wars
yeah a civil war one side comes out on
top and then you say
that's just gone that's gone right so uh
we with abraham lincoln right the
suspension of habeas corpus i think they
what are they they threatened to arrest
the uh the assembly in maryland i think
they arrested and killed people by the
state for for just simply disagreeing
with the centralized government at that
time well it's interesting you were
mentioning the fact that people have
really been propagandized to accept a
lot of these left-wing ideas but even so
going back to tim's comments about
may 29th and the way that's treated as
compared to january 6th for as
propagandized as public has been
according to polling data something like
two-thirds of people would like to see
an investigation into the 2020 riots
whereas less than half of american
citizens polled want an investigation
into january 6th so even though it would
be tremendously politically popular for
the republicans to look into the 2020
riots
i'm not going to hold my breath
what's interesting about the um the 2020
riots and being there covered on the
ground the majority of the businesses
that were burned down were black and
brown owned immigrant owned i was
actually i was an intern for the daily
call but my first night on the ground
was actually 5 29 and i've you know i've
never seen anything like that when they
were attacking secret service now that
night i don't know if you guys remember
but i um i broke the story of he was
with fox news at the time leelin vitter
he was assaulted by those black lives
matter supporters now could you imagine
if it was cnn jim acosta then it was the
other way around i mean we would they
would never let us forget about it i
guarantee people don't even remember
that leland got got assaulted because he
works for fox news but if it was jim
acosta oh man we would we wouldn't hear
the end of it i'll take it a step
further blm attacked cnn's headquarters
in atlanta oh yeah that's right and and
l.a
and for all the rhetoric we've heard
about how the media feels unsafe doing
their job as honest brokers because
people make memes of donald trump in a
wrestling match punching a person with
cnn's logo photoshopped over his face
when blm attacks them and is literally
riding at their front doors and breaking
into their building it's welcome mostly
it's that big of a deal it's mostly
peaceful they were like we it is fine we
understand um you know languages
remember the most
he's like they are mostly peaceful in
the police stations on fire behind them
iconic it was even iconic during the
riots of like uh black business owners
having to put signs saying this is black
owned like yeah don't burn me down and i
know drew you remember this when we were
in kenosha all the apartment buildings
have having to put signs saying hey kids
live here please don't burn it down that
was they did it again right before the
trial the written house trial when i
went out there i was driving down those
same streets and the same signs were out
there there was like this senior citizen
home that was like hey old people live
here
my favorite was those college kids that
were cheering on the blm protest and
we're like yeah oh then
and then they got a brick through the
window
we're with you and they kept throwing
more bricks and i'm like this is this is
the true reality of the consequences
that people don't realize that they have
to deal with thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 p.m and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you